when daniel sun hit that crane kick we
learned to never give up when Lloyd
Dobler lifted his boom box we learned
love is patient and when Johnny and baby
danced we learned how to come out of our
shells there's something magic about the
movies we watched in our youth those
moments that helped shape our budding
personalities like when Ferris Bueller
taught us you can never go too far Jack
Burton taught us saw on the reflexes and
the Ghostbusters taught us when someone
asks you if you're a god you see yes as
we get older though this magic fades
dampened by our age experience and
cynicism these days we bring so much
with us into the theater it's a miracle
we enjoy anything at all but we can have
that sense of wonder again and the
answer isn't in bigger special effects
sequels or reboots it's in characters we
care about doing things that excite or
inspire us like when Luke learns who his
father is
when Elliot learns how to say goodbye
and Dee learns that never get on the
freeway the answer is also in us
let's make movies magic again let's turn
off our phones and our cynicism let's
ignore reviews hype gossip and snark and
just enjoy the show like when we were
younger and George McFly taught us how
to stand up for ourselves The Goonies
taught us to never say die and peewee
taught us there's no basement at the
Alamo movies can still teach us a lot
about ourselves we just have to be
willing to learn
come back tomorrow
[Music]